[Musique]
bonsoir
alors j'ai pas le talent de mes
prédécesseurs ont géré didier moi je
mets de quelques nouvelles scènes
tablette on a deux vies et la deuxième
commence lorsqu'on se rend compte qu'on
en a qu'une
confucius mais at depuis le début de la
soirée on vous le répète c'est un terme
un thème bien ardue aujourd'hui pour ce
cycle de conférences au premier tedx ifa
de metz mais ô combien d'actualité
nous venons d'entendre le récit de huit
parcours de vie huit rencontres
extraordinaires qui ont chacune une
belle dimension et qui nous font nous
interroger sur nous mêmes car elle nous
interpelle
le point commun me semble-t-il c'est la
rupture comme si seule une rupture
pouvait générer une mutation une nuit
une mutation dans notre parcours de vie
une mutation de notre esprit de notre
coeur de notre coeur de notre
intelligence et surtout un moment
imprévus et qui nous terrorise dit il
m'a dit qui fait que je prenne des
respirations
nous sommes potentiellement toutes et
tous confrontés dans nos vies à ce
passage
cela peut être une chance ou une
malchance et bien souvent cela tient à
peu de choses une rencontre un regard un
concours de circonstances où un signe du
destin ou pourquoi pas le hasard
bertrand piccard le savanturiers
héritier d'une famille d'explorateurs et
de scientifiques mais aussi psychiatre
et l'auteur n'a tour du monde en ballon
en 1999 il vient d'achever un autre en
avion avec comme seul carburant
l'énergie solaire pour lui le ballon
c'est comme dans la vie lorsqu'on est
dans une impasse
il faut savoir changer d'altitude
changer d'altitude pour changer de
vision un ballon ça va au gré du vent
pour changer de direction
il faut monter ou descendre pour prendre
un vent différents
marcorelle a écrit que la force me soit
donné de supporter ce qui ne peut être
changée et le courage de changer ce qui
peut l'être mais aussi la sagesse de
distinguer l'un de l'autre en ce début
du troisième millénaire du 21e siècle
nous vivons la troisième grande rupture
une profonde mutation
un changement de paradigme même si tous
les sociologues les philosophes les
écrivains les économistes les
universitaires ne sont pas tous d'accord
sur cette division en trois parties je
crois qu'elle nous permet de mieux
appréhender ce que nous vivons
actuellement
première grande rupture la renaissance
va durer cent ans et va transformer le
monde du au xvième siècle c'est le
siècle de léonard de vinci
et pour ceux qui met pas beaucoup
l'histoire qu'un 115 la bataille de
marignan françois 1er c'est l'époque
du changement entre le monde médiéval et
l'époque moderne où les grandes
découvertes
les nouveaux modes de diffusion
d'information des échanges commerciaux
de la représentation du monde
deuxième grande transformation et nous
venons d'en parler le siècle des
lumières 50 ans d'une profonde mutation
qui va conduire la révolution française
pour la première fois dans l'histoire de
l'humanité
après l'expérimentation et 3 animaux et
on continuera à le faire dans l'espace
un coq un mouton et un canard l'homme va
prendre place dans une frêle nacelle
d'osier pour glisser dans les airs porté
par une bulle d'air chaud mais ce sont
aussi les mutations dans la médecine la
littérature l'art le commerce la
chirurgie les sciences en général
la france comptait 25 millions
d'habitants une grande partie de la
population avait faim d'autres mouret de
la peste la guerre régner et pourtant de
grandes choses ont été inventés
troisième mutation nous la vivons
actuellement est celle là elle nous
percute collectivement depuis 30 ans
sans nous en rendre compte
avec l'informatique et depuis les années
2000 avec le développement d'internet et
de ses applications
c'est une rupture sans précédent dans un
monde profondément bousculé
c'est la première fois dans l'histoire
de l'humanité que chacun veut dire
n'importe quoi à tout le monde avec les
réseaux sociaux internet a bouleversé
notre planète
le philosophe michel serres le décrit
bien dans son ouvrage la petite
poussette en expliquant que nos
civilisations occidentales ont déjà vécu
deux révolutions le passage de l'oral à
l'écrit
puis de l'écrit à l'imprimé ce furent
des périodes de crise comme celle que
nous vivons qui s'accompagne de
mutations politiques sociales et
cognitives
mais reprenons l'exemple de l'est on
note défricheurs dr lorsque le 21
novembre 1783 à paris le jeune enfant de
metz jean françois pilâtre de rozier
s'envole avec le marquis d'arlempdes
dans une frêle nacelle circulaire vous
un globe de 2200 mètres cubes c'est
aujourd'hui
un ballon moyens sait-il qu'il va donner
des ailes au monde entier
assurément non par plus que louis saez
qui le subventionne par l'intermédiaire
de calonne d'ailleurs pas plus que les
frères montgolfier qui ont inventé la
machine
pourtant avec l'invention du parachute
puis du ballon à gaz du dirigeable de
l'avion du planeur de l'hélicoptère
on va bientôt concevoir des fusées qui
vont aller sur la lune
explorez l'univers des pionners qui vont
accepter de mettre en danger leur vie
pour aller tourner autour de la terre
dans un vaisseau de géant qui permet de
capter chaque bruissement dans l'univers
et sur notre planète est grâce à cela
combien de progrès dans les sciences et
les techniques lui ce physicien et
chimiste qui a inventé le bas le masque
à gaz et les bougies et phosphorique
ils ont sept des allumettes entouré par
les esprits éclairés que son voltaire et
benjamin franklin réalise le rêve
d'icare persuadé que c'est la chaleur et
non la fumée qui fait monter les ballons
dans les airs avec lui l'un des rêves de
l'homme depuis le midi le mythe d'icare
volet est réalisée au-delà des
cathédrales dans une atmosphère réputé
un pur comme dans la vie pour se diriger
il a compris qu'il faut changer
d'altitude pour surmonter les montagnes
les écueils les situations impossibles
il a choisi les bons vents pour
atteindre son objectif
et pourtant ils n'avaient pas comme
devise c'est le prêter à mark twain
il ne savait pas que c'était impossible
alors il l'a fait il n'était pas
programmé pour devenir ce défricheur
désert sa passion l'a même conduit à se
rompre les os le 15 juin 10 785 en
tentant de traverser la manche en
rozière bas de toutes les manières il
aurait perdu la tête à la révolution
proches qu'il était du pouvoir royal
il a fait partie des 7000 innocent
malheureusement nous ne pouvons pas être
tous des êtres exceptionnels
parfois comme l'expliquent voltaire dans
son candide il nous suffit de cultiver
notre jardin
cela semble simple et pourtant avec ces
petits gestes nous contribuons aussi à
changer le monde sans en avoir toujours
conscience aujourd'hui l'époque nous
semble incompréhensible
avec la mondialisation objets connectés
le big data l'intelligence artificielle
et augmenter les bottes les nouvelles
formes de commerce de production
d'information rapidité la diversité de
l'information et de la communication
cela nous semble si compliqué de vivre
dans une société planétaire bien tenté
de se replier sur elle même dans l'abyme
qui semble se profiler nous fait peur
même si nous avons un pouvoir
gigantesque celui de commenter et
d'interagir avec ce qui se passe en
temps réel
à l'autre bout de la planète même si
nous sommes devenus des témoins et des
consom'acteurs de ce bouleversement que
nous avons du mal à comprendre quand il
est extraordinairement divers nous
devons pourtant avoir confiance en nous
plus que jamais car c'est notre avenir
et celui des générations qui vont suivre
que nous avons en main avec la
transition digital nous avons imaginé
déployer la transition énergétique à
maîtriser ses codes moderne qui peuvent
faire de nous des esclaves ou des
maîtres de notre destin la rupture que
nous vivons collectivement devrait nous
transcender les progrès dans la médecine
dans l'allongement de la durée de la vie
même si parfois ça se termine un peu
tragiquement nouvelles technologies qui
créent chaque jour de nouveaux métiers
devrait nous rendre confiance dans
l'avenir
mais peut-être que tout ceci est trop
brutale trop violent résister de m tant
de gens dans la rue pour que nous
puissions mesurer la chance de vivre
dans le nouveau monde de la troisième
rupture
je n'ai pas de réponse à vous apporter
juste un témoignage personnel lorsque
l'obstacle vous semble impossible à
sauter prenez de l'altitude garder
espoir et reprenaient confiance en vous
moi j'ai vécu de multiples ruptures ou
j'en ai même écrit un livre
même pas mort j'ai vécu une journée une
vie de journaliste témoin qui a été
fantastique sûr je me suis retrouvé un
jour saltimbanques créateur d'événements
sans doute par fidélité à mon histoire
familiale
ce fut une rupture douloureuse mais ô
combien enrichissante partager avec
l'être cher car seuls on ne peut pas
grand chose je me dois de vous confier
que la joie de milliers d'enfants et
d'adultes qui voit décollé quelques 500
montgolfière est un salaire qui vaut
tout l'or du monde
moi ce qui m'a toujours sauvée parce
qu'il n'a toujours permis de rebondir
même si je pensais que tout était fini
que ça ne valait plus la peine d'aller
plus loin
c'est bien de me dire que je peux servir
à quelque chose dans la vie si courte
que la nôtre de toutes les manières
comme disait il illustre inconnu jules
claretti j'aime toujours citer celui là
tout homme qui dirige qui fait quelque
chose qu'on a contre lui
ceux qui voudraient faire la même chose
ceux qui font précisément le contraire
et surtout la grande armée des gens
d'autant plus sévère qu'ils ne font rien
du tout même si les ruptures provoquent
des blessures
il ne faut jamais perdre l'envi d'être
et de faire permet témoins
en guise de conclusion d'être vulgaire
non rossier vive les ruptures ou fuck le
désespoir nous méritons mieux merci